The fact that request animation frame, runs once
and only once during a redraw cycle also
let's the browser optimize concurrent animations. SVG, CSS
transitions, scrolling, your own dom-based manipulation together, into
a single reflow and repaint cycle. Rather than,
each of these poking in in it's own
timer and updating the screen whenever it feels
like. This leads to much higher fidelity visual refreshes.
But, in addition to causing all these refreshes together,
this has the effect of locking the updates, to the
visual refresh rate as a maximum. You won't accidentally
call your drawing routine more than once during that magic
16.7 millisecond long refresh cycle, which would waste work.
Request animation frame won't be called again, until the current
frame is pushed out to the screen and it's
ready for another frame. And then finally, there's one more
key feature to request animation frame. Their callback won't
be called, if the browser tab isn't visible. That's,
if you're running the animation loop in a tab
and the user switiches away, the browser won't keep
calling the visual refresh callback, it will once it's
visible again. But, this means you won't be using
the CPU, the GPU or extra memory potentially. Which
will lead to longer battery life on a mobile device.